dear rank
sorry that joke's not better
um
my writer's on the picket line right now
[Music]
that's a joke
I don't have another person write my
stuff
I barely script this stuff as it is
anyway uh writer skills of America the
wga
is on strike now it's been a while since
this has happened but I am old enough to
remember the last time that it did and I
feel like it's worth prepping folks or
reminding them if they are my age or
older what we're in for and how long
lasting the effects will actually be
first before we get into all of that
let's talk about uh what the deal
actually is Writers Guild of America is
the union of writers in the Hollywood
System not necessarily specifically
located within Hollywood but um members
of the Union uh they get priority work
in anything that is uh of a certain
professional scale a certain Studio or a
network size there is an expectation to
have if not a complete staff of Union
writers at least a majority of them
depending on the specifics of the
production now the wga is one of a
couple of big unions within the
Hollywood System there's also the
Director's Guild the DGA there is the
Screen Actors Guild otherwise known as
sag actually Hollywood in general is a
very unionized town and business a lot
of it is in unions and Union sometimes
means that when contracts are up and
you're negotiating for the next cycle
well if negotiations right down
folks go on strike and the wga was not
able to resolve some conflicts with the
American motion picture and television
producers they
weren't able to come to an accord now
the main sticking point is it's what
you'd expect it to be probably yeah well
it is money related most union strikes
are either money or safety related and
since this is not a business or at least
an aspect of the business known for uh
worker compensation issues for injuries
and whatnot then yeah it is about uh the
direct income so residuals in this case
it has to do with the residuals coming
in on streaming now writers do get
residuals for streaming that's actually
one of the things that they got as a
concession when they struck the last
time and I will be talking about that
the thing is though
uh it's very clear that what it was that
had been arranged before which was done
before the full scope of what streaming
was going to look like was even clear so
the nature of the specifics of the
contract were in such a way that while
writers do get well if they are union
writers do get residuals off of
streaming it's currently being handled
in such a way that writers who have
gotten a lot of work on streaming who
were getting work say and network or
um at Major movie series before are
seeing a massive drop in their income so
while there aren't no residuals for uh
streaming writing they are not lining up
with with what they get compensated in
other avenues and the wga is looking to
remedy that as well as some other things
but the residuals is the big thing and
yeah they weren't able to come to an
agreement and so the strike is now going
on hey it's me in the editing phase just
real quick it isn't just residuals
there's also some issues over the threat
to getting rid of writers rooms breaking
that down real quick writers rooms are
used to produce TV shows and it allows
writers to basically have a salary and
be contracted for the full run of
however long a show is going or at the
very least for the length of its season
and those are going away in favor of
one-off contract situations which just
pay out far less and also are much less
stable I'll actually let Adam Khan over
take it from here and give his
explanation because he was quite
succinct this is a room that's existed
for decades where writers get together
and break a story and write scripts the
companies are trying to eliminate it
they're trying to make the room smaller
they're trying to employ us on a
freelance basis they'd rather we just
stay home and email scripts in and they
pay us a fee every once in a while and
we can't make a living that way and I'm
not really going to focus on the
political aspects of the strike I will
say broadly speaking I am pro-union and
uh solidarity to them good on them I
hope it goes their way
because my general thing and anyone
who's like oh they just want more monies
like no they want their fair share of
the money that's in the system
because like there's a ton of money in
this
it's just not going to them
and maybe some more of it should be
especially if folks who are focusing on
streaming writing are getting way less
than those in other areas of the
industry I say that's messed up I say
that's worth striking over but I'm not
going to dwell too long on that let's
talk about the Practical outcome of this
what's the actual impact going to be
well
um any wga writer
is not to be working on anything that
would be a Union Gig when you talk about
uh smaller independent stuff which don't
necessarily involve Union work or maybe
even have union workers but have
negotiated to not be working at union
wages it gets a little bit weird and
case specific but major Studios movie
studios television networks major
streaming services all work has stopped
for writing now the most immediate
impact of that is that basically any
show with a writing staff that has a
nightly output
is just done until this is resolved so
that's your late night talk show sort of
things that's your Tonight Show late
show Daily Show uh anything like that
Saturday Night Live that one's weekly
but you know anything where they have
quick turnaround
um and these things are not written and
produced well in advance they basically
are shot and aired later the same day or
close to it yep that stuff's all done
for the time being so that stuff's
already closed down anything that is
shot weekly uh you're also gonna see dry
up for the time being and they're just
they're just gonna have to settle for
reruns or putting something else in the
time slot they just basically can do
nothing
so that's the most immediate impact that
is seen
however
the period over which the impacts of a
prolonged strike and a guest from a lot
of experts is to nail down the
negotiations and get this thing settled
is probably going to take
a month maybe two
that's a lengthy strike that's a decent
length strike now that's far from the
longest strike that even the writers
guilds has ever taken much less any of
Hollywood has has taken but that is uh
pretty significant and that sets off a
chain reaction that we will be seeing
the effects of for a while and that's
where it helps to reference the last
time which that strike was in 2007 and I
forget how long it lasted off top my
head but it definitely lasted long
enough that we were seeing its impacts
well into the next year and that's the
thing I mentioned things with quick
turnaround like nightly talk shows or
whatnot that are just they're just toast
for the time being there's plenty of
stuff that is even in production right
now and obviously anything that's in
post-production you know that's already
been shot that's just going to move
forward as normal and even a lot of
stuff that's in production if the script
is locked in then that can move forward
more or less as normal
though possibly with still some impact
I'll Circle back to that again with some
examples of uh how that panned out last
time
but don't expect to see a major impact
on scripted high production TV shows or
movies this year
or at least not until the tail end of
the year
going into next year is when we're
really going to see the impacts now what
kind of impacts would those be that
would be so delayed well
a is generally going to result in
delayed projects things coming out just
flatly later than they're supposed to in
the case of network TV shows scripted
Network TV shows truncated or shortened
Seasons where they're just not going to
have as many uh episodes as they would
have otherwise and uh
we're gonna get some odd movies some
movies with some really underbaked
scripts because it's not that the
students can't move forward and use the
scripts that are written it's just the
writers can't do new work
so the thing is this strike didn't come
out of nowhere
it was bubbling up and everyone knew
there was a chance it could happen so
any smart Studio was going to try and
get in Finnish scripts before this
deadline hit and if they were planning
far enough in advance maybe they got a
decent number of finished scripts in and
they'll be okay to Coast for a while but
what that can also mean is
scripts may have been thrown together
hastily
to hit a deadline that would not have
been their deadline except for the
looming strike you get stuff thrown
together
haphazardly
which wouldn't be as much of a problem
in and of itself
except the the writers can't adjust the
script otherwise see I mentioned things
already in production are mostly going
to be an unaffected but not entirely
because depending on the nature of the
production especially if there are
reshoots on something once the initial
edit is done and they realize you know
what they're missing or what they could
use or need
writers are still on hand to write new
material revise the material sometimes
you sometimes you have a script doctor
or sometimes you have the original
scriptwriter you know on hand to make
adjustments to the script because of
things being altered or you know what is
or isn't working on screen or maybe a
certain actor is no longer available and
they're and their part needs to be
shortened or the location change or
whatever the writer has to be the one to
make those changes to the script the
director can't make those changes to the
script an actor can improv lines but an
actor can't make those changes to the
script that's part of the Union rules
the writers are the ones who work on it
and if they're not there and they're not
working then whatever problems are in
what is in theory a finished script
you can't really fix them not major
structural issues at any rate like again
actors can improve lines that's not the
problem it's if you get in there and
start shooting and realize oh wait like
because of this other thing that we
decided wasn't worth filming we now have
a plot hole and we can't write a new
scene to cover for it
because we're not allowed to do it
because it's a union gig and the writers
are striking
and that's how you get scripts like
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen that
was very much a writer's strike product
and when that movie came out everybody
was trying to blame everybody else for
the state of the thing but a lot of
people did Circle back on the idea of
well whether you want to blame the
screenwriters in the abstract at the
very least you have to Grant
whatever state the script was in whether
it was their fault or input of the
director's fault or whatever else it
couldn't be polished it couldn't be
fixed they were stuck with a very rough
script and a movie that had already been
set up and scheduled and whose budgetary
items and whose expected release date
were all locked in and the studio
couldn't really move them that much and
that's the other thing
you might just think to yourself a
couple months just delay stuff what's
the big problem well
fiscal years is the big problem
investors is the big problem
you are expected to still be making
product you are expected to still be
bringing in revenue and at the start of
your fiscal year you would have told
your investors here's the timing that
we're expecting for this stuff
and maybe you can move one thing out a
little bit but you can't move everything
out by months because suddenly you have
a massive hole where basically no income
is coming in
they can't afford that well they could
if they were willing to take a hit to
their growth because of course these
days it's not enough for a major
corporation to be profitable they have
to be more profitable than they were
last year and that's where we get in
just into just the inherent issues with
the current hyper capitalist hellscape
that we are existing in but uh you know
these things are expected to land at a
certain time in terms of when the money
is allocated to pay for them and when
they are expected to start generating
revenue and as I said yeah some things
you can delay I mean some movies do get
delayed some TV shows do get delayed but
you delay one thing and everything else
stays on schedule you can get away with
that
you delay everything
so stuff gets pushed forward
and that's also how you end up with what
I mentioned before with truncated uh
television seasons and things like that
because you'll have once the strike
eventually resolves you'll have Writers
come in who um are going to be coming in
and trying to put together their next
season of Television because you need to
you need to understand
the union rules isn't just that like you
can't turn in a script they can't work
on it at all now
it's a little bit of a squidgy thing
like how do you monitor what someone
does in their own time and if they're
writing in their own time you know
what's the thing but like if they get
caught doing that they could be expelled
from the Union
like that would be a big problem it's
one of those things where like
it's kind of hard to get caught doing
but if you do you're screwed
so
say a showrunner for a TV show even if
that first season's wrapped up done all
set
uh they can't work on the next season
they at all they can't it's a network
production they cannot work on it they
can think about it sure but they cannot
be typing up scripts to just be ready to
go for when the strike's over because
that's working that's what they're paid
to do and they're striking on that right
now
and so that's where you get situations
where they come back after the strike is
eventually resolved and suddenly the
network is going look we still expect
this we still were hoping for this show
to start airing at a certain time and
obviously we can't because we're
starting late but we still expect the
back end to land in the exact same time
so suddenly you lose the front half of
your season order because they're not
going to shift to the entire season
they're just gonna have the season start
late but still end when they plan to
have it end so suddenly you go from 20
episodes to 11. that's what happened to
shows like Heroes with its second season
Pushing Daisies was another one back in
the 2008 uh 2007-2008 strike that really
really took a hit for these exact kind
of reasons and that time as well that
strike was initiated by issues of
residuals at the time then the major
Focus was uh DVD
and things like that and residuals
related to those things uh it did set up
it did sort of understand that streaming
was on the horizon and so like the fact
that most streaming writing gigs are
union gigs that's actually thanks to
that eventual contract negotiation from
the last strike but again as I said they
didn't know exactly what that landscape
was going to look like and at this point
they want to renegotiate so that the
residuals actually line up with the kind
of living that you need to be able to
make to you know eat and have it be uh
continuous with the kind of residuals
that they would expect from television
uh you know Network television or movies
and currently it isn't we want to make
sure that writers are paid the same in
streaming as they are on television my
my first show was for True TV my second
show was for Netflix the show had the
exact same format but on Netflix we had
no minimums we had no protections we
were paid less the residuals are
literally one percent of what they were
yeah we're gonna see long-lasting
impacts and it's worth remembering now
because
we're gonna get into 2024
and we're gonna get shortened seasons of
television
and we're gonna get movies coming out
that it's like that thing seemed really
off that seemed really undercooked that
seemed like it had no polish at all like
with the story
this will be why
and like the thing is
writers get screwed a lot the wga has
struck more than any other guild in
Hollywood because they've had to because
writers are treated as disposable and
it's kind of understandable why on a
certain level because with movie stars
like they can be replaced but like it's
clear that you did so visibly you can
tell somebody else is there directors
depending on the nature of the flare
they bring the nature of the directorial
um touches and sort of visual signatures
and storytelling aspects that they bring
maybe you can tell when a director
changed when a writer changes
there aren't that many writers with that
clear distinctive Voice or at least
that's going to survive whatever
additional Flair is brought by the
actors and the directors so they are
seen as far more replaceable
they are saying that in theory if you
have a script if it's written by this
one writer versus this other writer
are people really going to notice the
difference that much
I mean maybe maybe not but it's a lot
harder to prove and so they're they're
seen as more
um theoretically replaceable disposable
and they are compensated much less
despite the fact that when the writer's
Guild strikes nothing gets done
because if you don't have a script you
can't get started
and if you don't have writers you can't
fix a script that isn't working
so I again I'll just say I think they're
well within the rise of strike
they're treated as one of the least
important aspects and I'm not
necessarily going to argue that they are
more important than the others but like
folks you need the writers
and I don't think they're asking for
anything unfair
but yeah we're gonna see the um
The Fallout of this for a while
what will be interesting is that this
actually is a potential Boon to
YouTubers
depending on how long this drag's on
because a lot of YouTube channels even
bigger YouTube channels
are non-union gigs
I mean I joked about it
I don't have a writer
I'm not a union
so it it has the potential
to fill a void and now it's not like
YouTube's suddenly going to crank out
more content but more people might find
themselves migrating here if too much
stuff dries up
um and in some cases because like I
don't watch a lot of late night stuff
but I do sometimes watch clips of late
night shows on YouTube which aren't
there right now
but if I found something that is still
being uploaded fresh and it's scratching
a similar rich
maybe maybe I migrate to that
that's just supposition on my part
um but yeah
this was also part of uh what influenced
the reality TV show boom
I mean part of it is you know they're
cheaper to produce because you know no
big names and you just you're usually
shooting in one location they're just
cheaper but beyond that uh they're
largely strike proof
they're kind of our writers to some
reality shows but not in the Union uh
manner in most cases and
that's another thing you can probably
expect is another surge of uh reality
shows
because
these networks got to put up something
these streaming services have to fill
the time with something and like they've
got a backlog sure but new stuff drives
new engagement drives growth and you
must have growth
the writers strike the writers Strike
Back
ah now that was stupid I'd rewrite it
but it's too late
did I really just do that joke again
okay I just proved that I don't properly
script these things some of the time
um but in any case yeah
the writer strike is uh is gonna have a
bigger impact than maybe you're even
thinking
what do you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
ensures that despite me not being in a
union I am able to do this for my living
even if you can't help me out that way
the usual YouTube stuff helps you know
what it is you don't need me to tell you
but
what I really want you to remember
striking or not
you're beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meeting and until next time this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
ronaldi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
foreign